so thank you number one for for being
here for talking about this um it's been
a while since you've had the opportunity
to do the gala what does it feel like to
be able to come back
it's been so long and and it i think
it's been probably three years
so um to actually be you know raising
money in person again we did very well
virtually actually yeah amazingly so
yeah thanks to our ceo mike ravenhill
and all the donors and all the friends
that we've sort of gathered over the
years that their community themselves
the people that help us with our
foundation so we had some great zooms
cocktail zooms but to be live is going
to be amazing yes it's going to be
fantastic now the foundation has been
doing great work for so long and you
know you can track the progress you can
track the the changes that you've made
in people's lives but what does it feel
like for you when you think about the
good that's been done how does that
change you
well i think we were saying earlier that
you know now we have a young baby and so
i it's actually that has had an impact
on me and what we do i mean sometimes
you know sometimes i'm not gonna lie you
go through the motions because there's
so many families that we help and back
in the day i used to be able to track
every family and visit every family and
now it's it's
sadly overwhelming that how many
families um
need need help but now having a baby
just sort of brings it all full circle
and i know cat feels the same way yeah
when you have a new baby you just can't
imagine
anything happening to them imagine as
they grow you can't imagine anything bad
happening to them but i think when
they're so little and innocent precious
that you just
um
you know i've known david for a long
time before we were even a couple and
i've known about his foundation so for
me it's incredible to watch uh what he
and
so many of his people who work for the
foundation have created it's really it's
incredible i mean they've raised so much
money
and it's going to be able to
be self-sufficient in the years to come
right because they've really been
ethical how they've raised money and how
they spend it so it's really it's a
special special thing you have done with
and we like to say that we're we're um
we're the brightest we're the only
bright spot in a family's worst day
and it truly is their worst day when
your child is sick
there's nothing worse than that so but
there's a foundation that will help you
pay for your mortgage in the second
house and the second car and take care
of all your needs so you can just
concentrate on your sick child yeah and
tomorrow night is going to be a
celebration uh catherine what are you
most excited about for the gala well i'm
so excited that they've uh i say they
but mike ravenhill who's the ceo
basically picked a broadway night this
had nothing to do with you or me i'm not
a broadway guy i've you know been on
broadway i've got lots of friends on
broadway which was fantastic um so it's
going to be great to get a little bit of
the broadway community together and
leslie odom who i did smash with all
those years ago i don't know if anyone
remembers that show but he has starred
in hamilton
and there's going to be just an amazing
night of great tunes and um you know
we'll do a little bit of jazz hands and
we're going to do wicked we're going to
do hamilton we're going to do smash
a bunch of different shows all in one
night so hopefully people are attending
or our broadway fans and if they're not
they'll become theater fans hopefully
are we going to get the jazz hands out
of you as well 100
yeah well david also
know this is very exciting we're doing
his big workshop uh the end of this
month in new york city for his musical
betty boop that he's been working on
forever um like since we've known each
other you've been working on it so any
coming into a four-week workshop
june 3rd presentation for investors if
we get the money yeah so chicago then
new york it's very appropriate that
we're having a broadway theme tonight to
help raise money for your foundation
because broadway is
you know just at the tip of the future
for me the tip of your fingers yeah
tip of your tip of your tongue tip your
tongue now going back to leslie allen jr
what a phenomenal talent with an amazing
guy was it mean to have his support
i was shocked i mean i i reached out to
him through a friend i don't know him
cat knows him
through me well actually through
yeah you're right i gave you this number
yeah you're right you're right
there are some celebrities that i know
that i think for sure and he was uh you
know there's certain people that have
followed my career and and like what i
do and they're happy to partake and then
there's others like i don't know who
this guy is but lesbian is one of those
guys that knows about me and and so he
he just jumped on it he said yes right
away which i was shocked yes he's a
great guy he's a big star he's a big
star yeah phenomenal
absolutely and you've got a lot of
amazing talent i mean this is the the
broadway theme after all you've got uh
the cast of wicked coming by now we we
just found out that cynthia rivo and
ariana grande are going to be cast in
the film version they won't be they
won't be they will be right
well what did you think about that
casting oh we love i think i mean i'm a
big ariana grande fan so and i'm a big
cynthia fan yeah so or both i'm a fan of
both of them yeah yeah i think it's
going to be great and i love who's
directing i think he's fantastic he's
the one who did um crazy rich asians
what's his name i don't know yeah it's
gonna be phenomenal it's gonna be great
but i think he's really really talented
so i think it's great yeah the thing is
that they have to do is you gotta
figure out
for a film
how to bust out in the song and not be
corny that's that's gonna be hard that's
the one thing if they crack that nut
they're gonna something has changed
within me
something is not the same
like that yes see and that that worked
just like that it did so just have you
run on and do it is is what i'm through
with playing by the rules
it's either you break out in a song like
that or david runs in and just does jazz
hands every other scene and that's how
we're gonna make it work yeah now you
guys have been collaborators for a long
time you know what have you learned
about each other
um through working together and
certainly working together on
this you know i've been asked that
excuse me i have we've been asked that
question before and i kind of have a
boring answer because truthfully we met
when i was a contestant on american idol
he and andrea bocelli were guest mentors
um season five
and we did all kinds of charity events
together he took me on the road to do
his you did my foundation i did 14 years
ago yes i did that um i did buchelli
shows with him where he'd come in so
like we've kind of always known each
other professionally first like
colleagues more than we obviously has
been romantic so we were friends for all
those years so nothing really surprises
me
working with him um like we were doing
the cat and dave show
uh yeah nothing really i mean you're not
quite as quick at the tech stuff as i am
but you know
i guess i don't know that's surprising
sorry cutie
um yeah so
but we've kind of is that an appropriate
answer that's a good answer yeah
now between you know work and life
family life the kids it can be difficult
to do things like get a date night would
the gala be considered a date night for
you guys is that what this this is
really about
[Laughter]
no it's working he's working
you know you start thinking about it a
few days well months in advance but a
few days before it comes i sort of pick
things off as they come i sort of you
know and then oh my god it's going to be
in four days i got to really work hard
and fortunately we have other people
that are working really hard on it but
it'll be a crunch i mean we have
rehearsal today we have a show tonight a
smaller show tonight rehearsal all day
tomorrow the big show tomorrow night
sunday night on sunday which is mother's
day yeah
exactly and he's got a whole thing
planned for mother's day so
is it is it a surprise do you know what
he has planned or i know we're not
revealing anything it's a joke i like
basically
i basically you can see me
um
yeah i mean i let him off the hook this
is a kind of a crazy it's a great cause
what we're doing um it's gonna be
exciting but it is a lot of work for him
and um so i'm excited just to yeah we we
are together all the time so it's true
yeah we're touring together together um
we're parenting together we're we
actually don't get very many date nights
though no no
no but we're together all the time so i
appreciate that we're together a lot yes
it would be no fun what's a perfect date
night for you well a gala would be great
just saying
this thing that you do when you just
break out into song is this something
that she does all the time are you like
hanging out in the office and then she
just busts in like i have to force
i have to force it but sometimes i'll
just wander over to the piano at home
and just start playing and then she'll
come and you know come behind me and put
her arms around me just start singing
but we don't do it a lot that was the
only but um i i love hearing her bust
out i mean she's got such a great voice
and she's mostly
singing in the shower and you're
probably like oh god i wish she would
shut up
no i know i think after after you know
you get betty boop going the next david
foster project has got to be like a
family album
where you're at no it's funny you should
say that because we've thought about
doing a christmas album not together but
her
her cat doing a christmas album we've
thought about doing a kids album yeah we
want to do kids songs that i've written
over the years by other kids and
starting to write for our our young
child now and and
it's probably not as easy as it sounds
because we we like we love rafi you
probably don't know who he is but he's a
great canadian
kids composer and um he's a lifesaver
honestly one song
every day day and night but it's great
but it's not as easy as it looks i don't
think because i've heard we're gonna
give it a shot yeah because some kids
albums are awesome like the music is
just awful
so it's gotta be top-notch yeah but it's
gotta be relatable to kids too so it's
great you know
well i i gotta say i think we can do it
yeah i'm looking forward to that i'm
looking forward to better and to
tomorrow night it's going to be
fantastic thank you so much we need to
get you a tick
tick i mean you do you get you a ticket
take it yeah come on too all right is
that a yeah like saying yes you heard it
on tv excited now sorry i said you got
to get a suit pressed yeah you're going
out yeah don't go like that now
wait what
thank you so much guys